this week on Brian Ross investigates
sneak-attack
a whistleblower lawsuit claims sales
reps for a major health company were
told to sneak into nursing homes bring
food for the staff and pose as essential
workers in order to recruit patients for
the company's hospice care business
these sales reps were being encouraged
to find creative ways and sneaky ways to
get themselves and their doughnuts or
their pizzas or whatever into these
facilities not to deliver health care
services but to sell sell sell all at
the very time the company's president
was meeting with the White House Covent
team task force it's a matter of life
and death and endangering not only the
patient's safety but essential health
care workers Plus as the covered 19
infection rates spikes across the
country what about those July fourth
presidential spectacles few masks little
social distancing we are now doing
unbelievably well and are in deep
testing on vaccines treatments and
therapeutics should the Republicans
stick with plans for a convention next
month in hard-hit Florida we're joined
by dr. William Schaffner and this week's
winners and losers in the media yes the
editor-in-chief of meaty ight shares his
fix see if you agree it's hard to watch
these things because you get so bored
from the law and crime trial Network
this is Brian Ross investigates good
evening and thank you for joining us and
welcome to our viewers on Facebook live
and You Tube live I'm joined tonight by
my colleague at the law and crime
Network Rhonda Schwartz and Rhonda we
begin with allegations of profits over
people during the pandemic
a whistleblower lawsuit alleges a major
company put the lives of nursing home
residents and the staff at risk in order
to sell their products and as we know
Rhonda that's
very vulnerable population that's right
Brian we knew from the beginning that
elderly folks were at greater risk from
this virus but the New York Times has
actually gone ahead to try to quantify
this by doing their own data study
collecting data from nursing homes and
long-term care facilities state by state
and their analysis shows that as many as
forty three percent of all US deaths
from the virus were elderly folks in
these homes as well as staff so it's a
very large percentage at risk and yet
Rhonda this lawsuit alleges that this
major company urged its sales reps to
sneak into nursing homes to sell sell
sell headquartered in Miami Florida
the Vitas health care company boasts in
this promotional video that it has been
a leader in providing hospice
end-of-life health care the patients in
14 states and the District of Columbia
we have over 12,000 professionals with
the expertise that comes from helping
the thousands of people day and night
who depend on us Kristina Ison a core of
San Mateo California is a sales
representative for Vitas it's her job to
go into hospitals and nursing homes and
sell the company's hospice care to those
in the final stages of life even she
says in a lawsuit filed last month
against Venus during the pandemic her
lawyer is Kayvan way when the outbreak
began escalating and various
municipalities and states began enacting
regulations shut down orders work from
home orders christina was alarmed that
as a non-essential worker a salesperson
basically that her employer was asking
her to willfully skirt these stay at
home orders and not only just skirt
those orders but go into facilities that
were on lockdown for the resident safety
and christina is not a nurse now she's
not a doctor's not a clinical person
right she's a salesperson that's correct
given the high rates of infection and
death state and federal health officials
put nursing homes on a strict lockdown
even families were kept out only
essential health care workers were
allowed to enter as we manage this
disease and the dynamic nature of this
moment we need to anticipate spread but
we also need to prioritize our focus and
the purpose of today's announcement is
to focus on specifically what we mean by
that most important thing again is to
protect the most vulnerable protect our
seniors but Cristina says she got this
phone message from her company that she
should call herself an essential worker
and gain access to nursing homes I'll be
just as are considered essential health
care workers report to work as scheduled
governor stay at home order does not
apply carrier be dispatched to
identifying herself as a health care
employee in the event that you require
proof of employment
there's also was encouragement from the
very top four sales reps to show their
successes so if you are able to get into
a lockdown facility be sure and document
it snap your selfies share them with the
group so we can all cheer you on
and be sure and send those up the chain
to corporate so that you can be featured
in the newsletter according to the
lawsuit these are some of the photos her
federal sales reps posted apparently
bringing snacks and food for nursing
home staff to help get them in Ryan
there's no medical reason to be taking
food into the facility and I'd like to
point out that this was not food for the
residents this was food for the doctors
and nurses and healthcare administrators
who could influence a referral and those
pictures that we've seen that she is
sent to us would tell us what we're
seeing there one of them says sneaky it
particularly troubling that they were
bragging about the fact that they were
willfully skirting the laws and anyone
who has a loved one in a nursing home
knows darn good and well that they can't
go visit their loved one in many cases
even if their loved one is dying and
they can't take a dozen donuts to their
loved one or even get into the facility
yet these sales reps were being
encouraged to find creative ways and
sneaky ways to get themselves and their
doughnuts or their pizzas or whatever
into these facilities not to deliver
health care services but to sell sell
sell the president and CEO of Vitas
health care and Nick Westfall declined
our invitation to appear on the program
and respond to the allegations in the
lawsuit Westfall was in Washington back
in March to meet with vice president
Pence and the Cova 19 task force where
the need to protect nursing homes was
prioritized generally we we we monitor
our nursing homes for abuse and neglect
but at the president's direction we're
going to focus exclusively on ensuring
that those who are in nursing homes
people operating the nursing homes like
many of the CEOs that we met with today
are complying with the new standards to
keep our elderly safe the very standards
the company has been violating according
to christina ice knockers lawsuit in a
statement Westfall thanked the Trump
administration saying quote it was clear
their top priority is to ensure health
care providers receive the full support
and resources necessary to deliver care
when and however appropriate and it's
disingenuous at best in my opinion
hypocritical is a term that comes to my
mind because what we have to remember is
that Vitas is currently on probation the
federal gov
but that is depositing 40 million
dollars every other week into their bank
account also brought charges against
them several years ago accusing them of
lying and cheating and stealing from the
government which by the way is you and
me the taxpayers and Vitas agreed to pay
I believe it was seventy five million
dollar fine and refrain from behaving
badly in the future and yet here we are
in the midst of a pandemic and now the
behavior that we complain of is not just
a matter of cheating the taxpayers it's
a matter of life and death and
endangering not only the patient's
safety but essential health care workers
and the families of those health care
workers which translates to all of us
potentially now Christina Ison doctors
lawyers says she is facing retaliation
for refusing to follow orders that she
go into nursing homes posing as an
essential health care worker and what's
been the impact on her to go through all
this well Christina is under a
tremendous amount of stress
she has stuck her neck out so to speak
as everyone knows jobs are hard to come
by in this economy and she has a good
job but as she said to me
no job no paycheck is worth endangering
so many people and so she has stood up
at her own risk because she says she
wants to be able to look herself in the
mirror in the morning and she can't be a
part of this for a paycheck or not she
just couldn't go along with the party
line and as we said
executives declined to appear in our
program Rhonda Schwartz have we heard
anything at all from the country we've
had no further response since we reached
out to them for an interview last week
Brian but one senior official from the
company was quoted in the media as
saying that their sales representatives
like Christina were essential to
providing hospice care so therefore they
were deemed essential medical employees
properly in their view call them
essential all right well coming up those
fourth of July celebrations very
presidential but were they super
spreaders of the covered 19 we'll talk
to dr. William Schaffner after a break
you're watching the long crime trial
Network with the pandemic raging
president Trump has now made good on his
threat to do withdraw from the well
world Earth Organization filing formal
papers today to pull the u.s. out of
that organization in all raises
questions about the role or lack of it
by President Trump in trying to stop the
spread of the virus to get more
information on that I talked this week
with dr. William Schaffner at Vanderbilt
University a leading expert on
preventive medicine and part of the
group that's now looking to see if
there's going to be an effective sexy
doctor Shafter thank you so much for
being with us tonight the headlines
paint a very dire picture the virus
appears to be in control yeah Brian it
looks as though the virus is all over
the United States and in many states I'd
say the majority it really is spreading
so we've fallen behind the virus is out
there spreading rather widely across the
country at the present time it's very
sobering it's indeed this past July
fourth we saw a president Trump speak
first about Rushmore and then at the
White House
very few masks were being worn very
little social distancing
and he said that 99% of the cases are
harmless is that true 99% of the cases
are not harmless I'm afraid he's
misinformed it's clear that a
substantial proportion of people have
very little illness or no symptoms at
all
but we still see any number of patients
that come into the hospital
need oxygen some of them have to be put
on ventilators and so that's really
serious disease obviously
hospitalizations are increasing in many
parts of the country intensive care unit
units are being stressed because of
limited beds and so I I think we have to
focus on the fact not on the the people
who don't have very many symptoms but on
the people who do have serious symptoms
furthermore those people with few
symptoms are spreaders they're moving
the virus around and they will encounter
people who have underlying illnesses or
who are older and it's those people who
we see in our clinics and boom we have
to admit to the hospital we see the
pictures of young people at the beach at
bars at restaurants they are the
spreaders aren't they yes those young
people who are being carefree rather
than careful are the great disseminators
now of this virus throughout our
communities and that's very unfortunate
we seem to have two populations people
who are older who have underlying
illnesses they're sheltering at home
being very careful wearing their masks
six-foot distancing having very careful
conversations about whether they ought
to meet with relatives that's one group
and then we have a rather large group of
people young people middle-aged people
with families who have cabin fever and
they wish to return to an old normal
they are out there
being rather blithe not wearing masks
frequently and certainly not observing
six-foot distancing and going to large
group events that's exactly the sort of
environment that the covert virus likes
it likes to be transmitted when people
are out there without masks and very
close together
dr. Schaffner is there a middle ground
given the push for reopening between
complete lockdown and the large
gatherings we're seeing is there a
middle ground of course there's a middle
ground Brian we're not going to lock
down again the economic implications of
that were just disastrous so what we
have to do is find that middle ground we
have to look for the new normal a new
normal we're wearing masks weird and
strange and a bit uncomfortable though
it is is the new normal by the way let
me say very quickly wearing masks is not
a political statement
the co-ed virus doesn't care whom you
vote for or if you vote at all it loves
to be transmitted so the mask is a
public health device it protects you the
wearer and even more importantly it
protects the people around you so
wearing the mask another middle road is
watch that six foot distancing we're
just going to have to be more separate
from each other and then as to group
gatherings yes that also is
discomforting because we can't go to a
lot of these large group events that we
used to enjoy we're going to have to
keep ourselves in smaller groupings and
quite frankly this will go on for the
next several months otherwise this virus
will continue to spread and make many
many people ill dr. Schaffer must be
distressing to you to see the
politicization of this whole episode
here the pandemic becomes a political
issue with people deciding to wear masks
or not based on their political beliefs
and with the president guard states
putting out information that's just not
true well having having politics enter
into this as I think everyone in public
health and clinical infectious diseases
just puzzled because the kovat virus
itself is totally a political and for to
have become a political event that bored
political issue I should say makes the
introduction of public health
interventions interventions much more
difficult because they become
misunderstood and so the notion clearly
is that this virus spreads readily we
don't have a vaccine yet so what is it
that we can do to inhibit the spread of
the virus and those things are clear
it's the masking the six-foot distancing
the avoiding large groups and being
sensible about that doesn't mean you
don't have to have fun it doesn't mean
you can't get together with friends and
still have a good time but you have to
do it in a very careful and somewhat
limited way doctor shafter let me ask
you about the issue of vaccine the
president said over the weekend that it
would be available very very soon well
before the end of the year you know a
lot about this is that the case well
we'll have to see how the vaccine trials
go
I am very comforted by the fact that the
Food and Drug Administration has
released this whole list of guidelines
things that have to be met criteria that
have to be met before a vaccine is
licensed and they focus on two things
those are the appropriate things does
the vaccine work and how well does it
work
that's effectiveness and the other is
safety have we had enough vaccine put
into sufficient volunteers a sufficient
number of volunteers so that we can
reasonably assure the American
population that we think this is a safe
and reasonably effective product and we
can give them not only good assurance
but what this vaccine will do we can
anticipate
how good it will be once we have that
information from tribe of the trials
then we can go out back see doctor
you've always stressed the importance of
not over promising and then under
delivery but isn't that what the
president seems to be doing we've had a
lot of over-promising here it's
troublesome because then people
anticipate kind of a quick answer and I
think there are no quick answers here
there may be speedy answers because
everybody's working hard but we
shouldn't over promise it's better to
under promise and then over deliver then
that's like a Christmas present
everybody's surprised and finally this
is occurring in an election year the
Republicans plan a convention in
Jacksonville Florida a state that's
being especially hard hit with the virus
is that a good idea well that sounds
like it gets a and X that is a wrong
answer next to all of the things it's
unlikely to be a masked event there
probably won't be very much social
distancing in fact there will be a lot
of social mixing and of course it's a
large public gathering ends the indoors
0 for 3 I think that that is most unwise
your recommendation then would be how
about having you we have to adopt to the
new normal a virtual convention let's do
that because we can still have the
spirit of getting together and electing
a new candidate reaffirming a candidate
but you just don't do it in person we're
doing so much virtually now we can
certainly manage that we have that sort
of innovation and cleverness in America
we can do that all right dr. William
Schaffner thank you once again so much
for being here and for your very
thoughtful words on all of this thanks
Brian good to be with you
next continued evidence of police
misconduct and police brutality we'll
talk with a black police chief whose
organization seeks to be the conscience
of law enforcement after a break you're
watching in the Long crime trial Network
despite all the calls for police reform
across the country Congress is now
adjourned without passing any major
legislation to reform the police I miss
all this calls for law and order and a
wave of crime in major cities across the
country this weekend Rhonda Schwartz yes
the challenge to law enforcement grew
worse with a series of horrifying
shootings around major cities around the
country and shopping malls city streets
backyards and worse of all worst of all
deaths six children were killed
including a six-year-old who is
celebrating it a party in her
grandmother's just playing in her
grandmother's backyard a terrible
escalating violence for law enforcement
to cope with indeed quite the issue and
caught in the middle of all this black
police chiefs who are hearing from both
sides from their fellow officers and
from their community I talked with a
leader of a group that seeks to be the
conscience for law enforcement chief
Davis thank you for joining us you are
the police chief in Hazel Crest Illinois
the next year's incoming president of
the Illinois Association of police
chiefs and a member of the board of the
National Association of black law
enforcement executives which calls
himself the conscience of law
enforcement I guess many people would
say does law enforcement have a
conscience well that is one of the
things that we hold law enforcement
accountable for is to have those
difficult conversations that often
members in our profession have not
historically had it or felt comfortable
having and do you find pushback from
other chiefs chiefs who are white there
I have seen pushback yes absolutely
there is pushback
people that may or may not believe that
that there is actually anything wrong or
that there needs to be any reform in law
enforcement so yes that does exist and
what is your reaction when you when you
hear that and what do you say to people
who are telling you to back off well you
know we're not going to be silenced
right is right and you know we the thing
is the idea is to develop relationships
and in relationships with many of my
counterparts while sometimes they may
not agree with some of the some of my
beliefs and some of our feelings quite
often I found that most of them will
most of them will at least respect that
and you know those folks who are who
they are we're going to keep fighting
the fight there's a lot of talk now
about defunding the police what's the
position of the organization on that so
what we believe so you have to get a
definition I guess and in our definition
our it's our belief that most folks are
asking that resources be put in other
places to help our communities and what
has happened is there were so many
social services that were defunded and
those a lot of those challenges that
those social services were dressing on a
day-to-day basis fell upon the police
and so we are definitely in favor of
resources being put into the into the
community to help us deal with some of
the challenges that we as law
enforcement do the best that we can with
but there are better equipped
professionals to deal with those things
but what did what happened is when a lot
of those social services were or
defunded and we started to have to deal
more with those things such as
homelessness substance abuse and mental
illness we weren't giving the we weren't
given the funding that they were using
private previously with those social
service efforts so you know we do the
best that we can but we are all for
additional resources to help the
community but what that does mean
doesn't it is that there'll be fewer
police officers on the street if your is
less money for police and this is a time
with a wave of violence of some of
America's major cities including Chicago
and nearby absolutely absolutely and you
know there's got to be that's why this
has got to be a collaborative effort
the community and the police coming -
coming together to come up with
solutions historically law enforcement
has decided how they're going to police
communities without much input from
those communities and and and coming
together we can come up with meaningful
efforts that will help us as a police
department and as law enforcement to
most effectively help our communities
out while doing it in an appropriate in
an appropriate way so that we're serving
them and not just policing the entire
community policing is always political
but never more so than it is right now
in the presidential election with the
president Trump calling for law and
order do you feel any way that you're in
line with him that he's overstating the
problems well the problems being in line
with him from a solution standpoint I
don't know that we're in line with him
from a solution standpoint law the law
and order stance has been one of the
things that's damaged the relationship
between law enforcement and communities
of color you know if you if you look at
look back at the history of law
enforcement you know what started out
slave catchers is how law enforcement
started out in this country and then it
evolved as the civil rights era came
into play you'd see law enforcement for
the people who were putting dogs on
women and kids and their Sunday best and
when we got beyond the Jim Crow laws
then you know we started dealing with
things it would have any enforced
enforced Jim Crow laws so that's just
been the history of law enforcement
we're marginalizing and coming
specifically with the black community so
you know that that is entrenched in the
culture of law enforcement and it's
damaged the relationship over the years
and we have to work so I won't even say
rebuild I said build relationships with
communities of color and do you find
yourself personally torn between the
law-enforcement community and the black
community they should necessarily be at
odds but it seems more and more they
perhaps are so it does present as
challenges but for me I look at it as
opportunity because I bring a unique
perspective as a black chief and first
and foremost as a black man the worst
encounters that I've personally
with law enforcement they're the two
worst encounters that I had in my
lifetime have both been when I was a
police officer and the officers knew I
was a police officer and in one instance
I was actually a police chief and the
person knew I was a police chief so you
know there's there's work to be done
from a cultural standpoint and we have
most of our officers are out there every
day doing the best that they can with
what they've got to try to keep
community safe but we from a leadership
standpoint we have to make sure that
we're setting the tone properly so that
we're effectively servicing our
communities I'm intrigued by what you
said what happened in those two
incidents where you were a police
officer of police chief well when I was
stopped on a traffic stop and it was by
an officer in a neighboring community
who had a history of doing racist and
just write straight-out racist racist
things in the community and he was
allowed to stay with that department and
we had a major encounter which could
have ended up being a deadly and very
could've well ended up being a deadly
encounter the other one my son was a
victim in a crime in an area in a
community nearby and we were just going
to check on the status of his case and
one of the officers there came out and
told me I know who you are I don't care
who you are you don't tell us how to run
our Police Department get out of here
and you know I just dismissed me and and
that guy ended up going to federal
prison for civil rights violations but
there are people like that exist that
exist and they are allowed to exist in
police departments and those are the
people that we're talking about we're
talking about the bad actors in law
enforcement your organization the
National Association of black law
enforcement executives has issued a
four-point guidelines one of them is
training for de-escalation I want to ask
you about what we saw recently on the
news about the officer in Miami in Dade
County Florida at the airport there who
absolutely took a swing and a woman who
was having a disagreement with that she
apparently she had missed her flight and
he just hauled off and punched her right
in the mouth the real sucker punch
that's not de-escalation is it
no absolutely that's an assault you know
that that's somebody who just lost
control the officer lost control you
know we're we're trained to deal with
people with in situations that are not
good that's what they they call us and
we're supposed to be the professional in
those situations and I were just
somebody who just totally lost it
there's got to be consequences for
actions like that you also call on other
officers to be obliged to interfere to
get in the way if somebody's using
inappropriate violence an officer using
inappropriate violence as was the case
with George Floyd it's a nice idea but
our police officer is really gonna do
that to one another once again I'll go
back to that word culture that's where
it's the culture has to be such that
officers are comfortable and interceding
and one of the things to promote that is
that there's work there are account
there's accountability for everybody
just like the people the officers that
were there with George Floyd all those
guys ended up getting charged now what
ultimately will happen til up to all
four of them I don't know but they're
all held accountable and when officers
see that they're gonna be accountable
for omission just as much as Cole
mission then they're gonna have to think
about instances like that they may have
to wear they may have turned the other
cheek we know over the years about the
so called blue line police protect one
another are you really able to change
that you think so culture you know I
talked about the history culture is a
hard nut to crack and it's not something
that's gonna happen I don't know that
it'll happen in my career but I think
what we need to do is we plant those
seeds for the growth of the cultural
change we come up with a strategic plan
to change things culturally and when we
plant those seeds we just have to wait I
just pray that I'm able to plant those
seeds and at that oak tree is able to
grow a little seeds that are planted so
and Mike my grandkids and my kids are my
age that they will see effective change
in culture and law enforcement and
finally chief after all you've seen in
the past few months on the streets of
Minneapolis Atlanta Louisville all over
the country Miami do you ever just give
up full of despair like there's really
no hope here
we can't give up can't give up if you're
truly about the change you cannot give
up I've been fighting it I look at this
as opportunity I'm a glass-half-full guy
and I look at this as opportunity I've
been fighting this fight to try to
educate my peers on the in justices that
happen to black people and how we as law
enforcement leaders have to address
these issues and I try to educate my
colleagues that don't necessarily look
like me as to some of the things that
I've personally been exposed to to try
to bring them into understanding so that
they can have empathy and so that we can
that empathy can can flow down to the
people that we lead and for me we got to
look at this as opportunity and you know
I believe that this this perfect storm
that God has put us in right now is
opportunity for our country and for our
profession to move forward Chief
Mitchell Davis thank you so much for
joining us tonight yes sir thank you so
much coming up next this week's winners
and losers in the media see if you agree
with the editors of media what they had
to say about the power couple at the
White House Katie and Steve Miller after
a break you're watching the law on crime
trial never
back now with this week's winners in the
media and the losers as well as chosen
by the editors of media we're joined by
the editor-in-chief of beady-eyed Aidan
McLaughlin media of course like blonde
Tron Tron work part of the Dan Abrams a
media empire and in your first winner
this week was the NBC News team that
broke a big story about Jeffrey Epstein
let's take a look at the clip ghilane
Maxwell who of course is we've talked
about Stephanie is somebody who has been
a longtime confidant and friend of
Jeffrey Epstein and who a number of his
victims say recruited them to be
sexually abused and trafficked by
Jeffrey Epstein charges and accusations
she's always previously denied has been
arrested by the FBI and is going to be
charged by federal prosecutors in
Manhattan so they broke me arrest story
right Adan yeah so this has been one of
the biggest stories of the past week it
was the arrest by the FBI of ghilane
Maxwell who is Jeffrey Epstein longtime
girlfriend who has been under
investigation by the FBI for some time
now now that major bombshell story which
I don't know about you Brian but I
didn't see coming was broke by NBC News
New York they're a team that covers
investigations and law and they
basically broke news that ghilane had
been arrested by the FBI and then
shortly followed it up with a report on
the charges which stemmed back decades
and involve Glenn Maxwell basically
grooming underage girls for sex with
Jeffrey Epstein and herself so there's
six charges in that indictment it's a
huge story piggybacking off the Jeffrey
Epstein story that obviously had a sort
of early end when he killed himself
inside a Manhattan jail last year you're
right no one has better source inside of
the FBI and NYPD than Jonathan tensed
his team at NBC News in New York you're
first loser with the group from Fox at
the show outnumbered let's take a look
at what they had to say it's hard
to watch these things because you get so
bored you want to just watch the clips
afterwards because it's so slow and he
speaks so slow and there's so much
stumbling but I forced myself and it was
kind of amazing because it was I mean he
his eyes were kind of empty and who who
is he supposed to call on next I mean
dude think he have the questions ahead
of time and he was sort of had an order
of people the gym was nearly empty when
you saw the whole thing they're taking
shots at Joe Biden right Aiden right to
put aside the fact that you know a news
person is just basically calling a Joe
Biden's speech boring and you know that
they expect more entertainment value out
of it um the what you saw Melissa
Francis who's that Fox News host do
there she wasn't the only one on the
panel guilty of this is push this
conspiracy theory that Joe Biden and
somehow coordinated with the reporters
at that event to screen their question
and so that he was sort of reading off
they claimed that he was sort of reading
off the teleprompter the answers that
were pre-written based on the reporter's
question that got pushed by President
Donald Trump as well it's complete
nonsense
there was a Fox News reporter at that
Joe Biden presser the Fox News reporter
did not pass his question to Joe Biden
team the screen before the press
conference so you know President Donald
Trump pushing that conspiracy theory is
one thing it was pretty disappointing to
see the next day after it had already
been debunked members of this Fox News
panel push it as well so that's why we
made them losers that day and did they
ever correct the record well you know we
went back and forth with Fox News
communications on this they were
basically claiming that it they were
just asking questions and that it was
just sort of they were floating you know
what might have happened at the presser
but it was such a silly question to ask
and one that was already debunked so you
know it the idea that there was a
segment dedicated to that is sort of
absurd you're next o winner was of all
things Newsmax TV let's look at this
clip from Fox the gap between Biden
leading and the president falling behind
is a reflection of the polls basically
also showing a disapproval of kind of
the way the coronavirus has been
now the electoral college could go a
very different way but it's hard for you
to come up with the numbers that the
president needs to win at the moment and
so why are they winners Newsmax
right so president dong Trump is
frequently in the past couple weeks
expressed his disapproval with Fox
News's weekend coverage we know that Fox
News is the president's favorite Network
but he's often tuned in on the weekends
and seen coverage that he finds that I
guess not
you know praiseworthy enough of his
administration that happened again on
Sunday that segment you just watched was
covering his poll numbers and him
trailing behind Joe Biden up in the
upcoming 20/20 election now he tweeted
that afternoon and basically instructed
his followers to stop watching Fox News
and to start watching news max in OAM
which are these two conservative news
outlets and TV networks that are far
more Pro Trump and Fox News if you can
believe that
the thing about news max is they still
have a pretty tiny audience compared to
Fox News they average about 20,000
viewers whereas Fox News's viewers are
in the million nonetheless getting a
presidential tweet and a shout-out news
max was mentioned in the president and
president Donald Trump's tweet that's
got to send some attention their way and
they got a good deal of news coverage
out of it as well so it was a win for
the network he has president before is
it making any difference to their bottom
line or to their ratings recently he's
praised Oh a N one American news network
a lot more than news max the first time
he's praised news max in a while which
is interesting because we know he's very
good friends with Chris ruddy who runs
news max um it's unclear whether or not
that is directed actually any viewers
towards the network I think we'd have to
wait for the end of this week to see
whether or not the ratings go up to any
extent because he shouted them out on
Sunday so we're gonna be looking at that
- and just tracking to see if they get
any sort of booth permit and I assume
news
Max is glad to have the presidential
seal of approval yeah I think it's
something that's coveted by OE and a lot
I'm sure News max is also excited to
have the shoutout from President Donald
Trump you know they just hired Sean
Spicer to host his own show on the
network so you know they're clearly
trying to make inroads with the
president and at least in faith so you
know it seems to be working at least to
some extent
and today's big loser or the White House
power couple Katie and Steve Miller
let's take a clip I'll take a look at
the clip from NBC News about them Katie
Miller told Jacob Soboroff quote my
family and colleagues told me that when
I have kids I'll think about the
separations differently but I don't
think so Homeland Security sent me to
the border to see the separations for
myself to try to make me more
compassionate but it didn't work
end quote Jacob responds quote it didn't
work I will never forget what I saw
seriously are you a white nationalist he
asked exasperated no she said but I
believe if you come to America you
should assimilate why do we need to have
like Little Havana
so Rachel Maddow they're explaining the
quotations from Katie Miller why are
they such a power couple and why are
they losers yeah so basically that was
Jacob Soboroff an NBC News reporter as
an upcoming book about the family
separation at the us-mexico border and
you know Rachel Maddow was interviewing
Jacob Soboroff about that book and he
actually got quotes from Katie Miller
who is you know it's rare that we
actually hear comments public comments
from her she's a vice president Mike
Pence's communications director um and
she is fairly behind-the-scenes presence
at the White House she really got
popular last year when it was revealed
that she was marrying even Miller who is
a much more popular or at least famous
figure in the White House as president
Donald Trump's top advisor he basically
takes much of the credit for president
Donald Trump's right-wing immigration
policy so when it was real that she was
marrying Jaden Miller but she became
a well-known figure you know not just in
within DC now I haven't heard you know a
single interview with her since she
became well-known and these are some of
the first comments that I've seen it
kind of you know reading them and kind
of makes sense as to why her and Stephen
Miller so aligned on these issues but it
was a pretty disturbing quote you know
she says that she went down to the
border to see the detention Phyllis
facilities and felt no compassion she
also has a sort of odd comment about you
know why the United States needs a
little Havana which is sort of a
historically challenged comment to make
even you know every other American city
is named after a city abroad so it was a
comment from her weird quote and it got
thoroughly panned on social media all
right agent McLaughlin thank you so much
for joining us and thanks to all of you
for watching and thanks to the staff at
law and crime we're getting is on the
air and off the air
[Music]